B I think we need to protect Richard
Simmons at
all do we put him in like what are the
what are those the what are the like the
seed bunkers that we need to keep
Society alive it's in Norway the seed
bank get get Simmons in there put him in
put his come in there I mean I just
meant him oh okay I was just it could be
two kinds of seeds we could get all
freeze freeze the jizz freeze the whole
guy I don't know what he's up for if we
needed to make a seed bank that was
actual sperm of like great men who would
we who would we
off who do we pin down and crank off for
the good of humanity like we'd have to
get like who are we going to pull start
in the event of a total Global disaster
set aside what you think about the
person just the fact that they we would
need like Trump we would need his like
he's obviously like super
sperm I picture him as a real gluey kind
of guy you like he seems he seems pretty
dehydrated like a real drib apparently
allegedly he's like had syphilis like if
you have that kind of energy and a
orange skin and that kind of hair is
this uh uh what is it side effect or
what is it called I I don't like him
either but are we just making stuff up
are we just like look everything he is
it's
syphilis I mean apparently what else
what's your
explanation cuz the guy is a fucking
animal
yeah I do I am curious about like the
health regimen they just keep these guys
propped up at that age it's definitely
ater all allegedly really do you think
just not covered in soup you know I
can't I have to take three naps a day
how are these guys like going to nine
cities a day running for president being
in on that yeah the plane Air Force One
must be real comfy it looks pretty cozy
like good like yeah they're napping
they're getting yeah yeah that's I want
to go back to the seed Farm thing
because I realized I described Donald
Trump J is gluey and it upset me and I I
don't want to edit it out but I want to
stop talking about that
part is has come
different
consistencies I'm not making accusations
but I would guess that you would know
better than
me not implying anything but experience
level I'm just one one to one over here
I don't spent a ton of time looking at
come like you've definely seen your come
way more way more but is it different
consistencies based on what you've eaten
or hydration or Al hydration level
altitude that I haven't checked okay oh
man I was in Denver it was it was
everywhere get off the
ceiling like does it get thinner the air
pressure that's what it does cuz I feel
like sometimes there's a lot and other
times there's not a lot that's the only
thing I've ever noticed I'm just looking
to clean it up I'm not really like I'm
not really like testing it like like the
pH levels like it's pool water I'm just
like well we've done this
again here's here's old shame icing
let's get that let's get in the shower
your new special like destroyed me when
you were talking about I I will spoil it
fine um it's my brand spoiling things
yeah that you have to masturbate in this
very special room in this new house I'll
just leave it at
that oh that sounds that's a great
teaser to watch a
special like what is the relationship to
masturbating as an adult man in a
relationship I feel like it's more work
than it's worth emotionally from what
feels like if You' got like a car in
storage and know you got to turn it on
just to get the fluid through the
pipes like it feels like a formality it
feels like a maintenance I mean if we're
getting there if that's where we're
going with it there is a bit like it
I've I had thought about I was mixed
thoughts of
like is it like oh his boners aren't
going to be around forever you you know
real use it well you got it kind of
thing is that a thing to keep the come
up you have to I'm not saying it's a
thing I'm just giving you my thought
process which is not based in any
science or medical knowledge but it's
like well it's there you know is it ever
just feel masturbatory like you're like
I guess I should I have like 20 minutes
to kill yeah all the time that's how I
on masturbation it's only when I'm like
I have like 20 minutes exactly to
kill it's the only time it time to take
30 minutes to do
this time to be late for this thing
how's 10 minutes late here I'm like
should I go on Instagram should I go on
Tik Tok should I engage in the comments
should I that stuff's toxic and and I'm
like I have 20 that like in my mind it's
a good way to spend 20 minutes and just
to yeah make sure all the equipment's
still popping better slap one
out yeah I it is kind like and then
there's a point where you're like well
do I feel good that I did that do was
that a nice thing for myself like it oh
no of course I don't feel good I don't
have a healthy attitude towards sex like
no I'm now now I'm praying to a god I
don't believe in anymore for forgiveness
for something that's normal cool I'm
glad I did this again today you talked
in your new special about God not being
real I feel like everyone now like even
if you don't believe in God everyone's
got like a religion something that it
checks that box whether it's like their
crystals whether it's their like
wellness and I get discussing that
CrossFit or like they've got something
that's taken the place of religion do
you have what's your like religion no I
don't have anything I don't I don't I
think I think I've not to sound
altruistic but I think I feel better
when I know i' like oh I was nice today
I was I was like a nice person today I
wasn't a jerk I I'm real bad I like shit
talking way too much and it's not
healthy everybody all the time it's not
good I don't have anything on Deck go I
don't even have anything on on Deck
go so a lot of podcasters just take on
any sponsor willy-nilly because they
have to pay for you know lawyers for
their DUIs and settlements from
disgruntled employees they hug too long
not this guy never hugged anyone not
once also I just don't take on any
sponsor like gen youell skincare I was
already using this before they wanted to
sponsor the podcast Dr Drew told me
about it off camera when he did the
podcast cuz I asked I asked why he
looked so young I was like can you give
me the baby blood hookup or whatever
you're doing and he was like it's not
baby blood sweetheart it's genu cell I'm
very specific about what I put on my
skin as y'all know I make my own face
oil double Virgo here okay so many
products are just shit in a bottle let's
be on they're scam snake oil trash
garbage nonsense that you overpay for
that probably give you cancer allegedly
not gen youell I got obsessed with the
Gen 90 it's the new instant wrinkle
treatment from genu cell I'll even put
it on my baby I don't care I've got my
baby right here he's starting to look
old he's a month I'm like M we got to
make sure that you know you don't
embarrass your mom over here we're
trying to get you a Pampers campaign gen
90 instantly reduces the appearance of
wrinkles anywhere you use it and I mean
anywhere it made my
eye it made my eye wrinkles go down like
right away I think God got confused my
prayers crossed I asked for my crows to
keep leaving tools not for crow's feet
around my
eyes God such a silly goose isn't he
genus cell is a natural clean and free
from mineral oil paramin and harmful
chemicals type of product formulated by
a compounding pharmacist it's
crueltyfree gen 90 is on sale now at gen
usell.com and it's of course included in
the bestseller package order right now
at genell g n
u.com Whitney GE
n.com Whitney free shipping on all
orders J usell.com
Whitney love you it's 2024 so now let's
talk about something important if you
get injured by a person place or thing
you deserve to get paid life can be
crazy sometimes the other day the
parking lot uh I was at that sounds
weird that sounds like I just go hang in
parking lots I don't not anyway in the
parking lot do you ever just sit in a
parking lot and just like
contemplate your I do hang out I really
do the point is there was a homeless man
this guy runs at me with a sword and
then I went to the deli and came back
after I got a weird salad and there was
this girl in a Prius it's always a Prius
parked truly an inch from my car okay
she had a leopard covered seats which is
like already tells me everything I know
about you
Sagittarius
and so I can't get into my car cuz she's
parked so close to me okay so first of
all F you and the horse you ran it do
you ride them or run them I'm really
like experimenting with a lot of very
famous popular adages that I know
nothing about i' learned a week ago that
was the elephant in the room not the
elephant in the living room so I don't
need any of this shit from any of you I
had to crawl through my driver's side
okay cuz this monster Parks an inch away
from me I almost get impaled in a very
valuable place by my thing that puts the
car in park and I know that this is not
illegal I'm just saying people are dumb
and on drugs and you guys got to protect
yourself you got to be ready for
anything in 2024 the only good news at
this point is that one person's
negligence can result in another's
settlement if you're in an accident not
calling a lawyer means you could be
leaving money on the table okay when
you're seriously hurt your injury could
be worth millions okay look I just 3D
printed a human child birth is hard
hiring Morgan and Morgan is easy Morgan
and Morgan is America's largest injury
Law Firm they have over 100 offices
Nationwide and more than 1,000 lawyers
with over $20 billion recovered for over
500,000 clients Morgan and Morgan has a
proven track record of fighting till you
get your fair and full compensation
submitting an injury claim with Morgan
to Morgan is so easy okay having a baby
crowning alone hard submitting an injury
claim with Morgan and Morgan easy if
you're ever injured you can check out
Morgan and Morgan their fee is free and
unless they win for more information go
to forthepeople.com SLG good you or dial
pound law from your cell phone that's
forthepeople.com good for you or pound
law pound 529 from your cell phone this
is a paid
AO I think you're like one of the
funniest Comics ever get that I really
do it makes trying to be better about
compliments you know what's weird thank
you you did close your eyes so we didn't
make eye contact I actually appreciate
part
thank you noticing this hole in the
table I'm already sweating but it's kind
of like there's when you're a comic and
you watch other people do comedy there's
like that's funny you know what I mean
like that's funny you know that's a good
joke you know oh that's funny and then
the next level is like jealousy you're
like I'll never be that good and then
there's comedy that actually makes a
comic be a fan of comedy and just get to
be like someone in the audience yeah and
watching your last special I was just
like a person watching comedy oh that
that that means a lot thank you that's
the nicest thing I've ever said to
anyone no even if it sounds weird
because of my personality and voice no I
even if it sounds weird because of
everything about I know it sounds like
I'm gaslighting you no I I know what you
mean though like you forget that this is
like um I'm just being entertained like
the people sitting in the audience yep
honestly moving to Portland has been one
of the best because now I go and I I
don't watch comedy specials on TV I'm a
little worried like first off I see
enough comedy but I'm a little worried
about the Osmos of consuming it in the
background at home or something
interesting cuz you worry it'll affect
so at least I can like have some
plausible deniability as to like the the
the originality of the stuff that's
coming out it shows cuz I mean people
say like he's West Coast to tell like
this what you know like just in terms of
how much everybody loves you and you not
yeah I was going to like not not not on
the humor level tou what's your do you
like write jokes and then start to see
connections and call backs and sto start
just getting bigger as you tell them or
do you write everything I mean you like
you know when you're like oh I'm about
to repeat this story cuz this group
hasn't heard it yet yeah I'll spice it
up a little more from last time make it
fun for me you know oh yeah yeah and
then you start doing that and all of a
sudden you're like oh man I'm telling
the same bullshit story for 30 minutes
instead of 10 minutes because you found
this detail that's funny you're like oh
if I go off on this I had this joke
about the G the grocery store but I saw
a brand of something I bought once when
I was a kid and a crazy thing like you
start adding all that stuff onto it yeah
yeah it just I think it just you do
comedy long enough that you start it's
I'm not saying it's healthy yeah yeah
like processing everything like oh
that'll be this that'll turn into this
does it ever turn off in your head it's
always kind of in the back of your mind
yeah I just got a lot better about
writing notes so I could not worry about
forgetting things yeah cuz my memory
went to absolute shit what is that is
that new is that all of us
was it co was it was it not having a
checkin with the world for a few years
was it co was it us looking at our
screens all day and frying our brains
was it we've taken in so much
information that we expect to actually
retain all of it when we never were
designed for that like everyone I know
is like I can't remember
shit yeah I I I I was wondering like
part of me I thought it was just age
like okay now we got enough experience
that like I I'm like hoarding memories
like I have to have the the TR that
remind me of the thing around me like
give it a rest dude it's fine yeah you
know you went to Disneyland when you
were seven Let It Go nothing happen like
you like collect things like you can't
throw no I do I do have like I'm not
full hoarder but there's certain things
that I've like ass this room coming
after hoarders would be a big big swing
I was kind I'm like looking at there's a
lot going on there's a lot of details in
here but it's also a set so yeah yeah
it's for it's in my home this is my I
sleeping there's a horse thing going on
yeah but it's like you can't there's
something that happens when I don't know
if it's like Terror management Theory
like which is like the idea that we know
that we're going to die so we have to
start collecting things to feel a sense
of permanence or something you cheer for
teams you pick a play like some to make
you feel like you're not going to die or
like will have some kind of lasting
effect who know that's why people like
like trophies and plaques and family
crests and shit like that there's a
point where you're just like I have six
horse things like I mean I also have OCD
but I'm like I I have to have this one
so this one like has a friend and then
it just turns into like I can't not buy
it it's like guys looking at butts
you're just like let me just I know I'm
going to look I have to just look at it
and then I can stop looking at it is
that what it is hor vintage horse stuff
for me is like guys looking at women's
butts it's not like sure yeah you you're
just like there it is moving on right
you know what I
mean I'm trying to think if that's how I
look at
butts well you live in Portland all the
women are like lesbians in burlap
likeall everybody's got butts everyone
in Portland just like dresses like a a
janitor and a Broadway play for no
reason like a fisherman I like how the
Broadway play went cop a janitor but
like but there's theatrics to it there
is you're kind of like that's a brand
new pair of aged vintage jeans I think
there there is that there's the
stereotypes of it but then there's also
just it's a city it's got everything you
want you spent a lot of time defending
Portland I feel like yeah I just bought
a house there I got I made my myself a
permanent part of the community I got I
got to be on
board come on we're in La at least the
butts are real up
there I W like in Venice yesterday I saw
a woman that was shaped I'm like you're
anime you're not real what is that
you're you're a
hologram it's a it's a well-shaped
hologram but no nothing about you looks
like you are comfortable with what
you've done to
yourself it does look like the all the
women I feel like look the same to me I
don't know if it's the contouring makeup
or what it is oh yeah the contouring and
the body is like I don't know I have
fake my is well I mean again I've got
stupid tattoos but they've made me feel
better when I got them if it makes you
feel better to get it then feel better I
do not think I could ever date a guy
without
tattoos oh really I look at somebody
without tattoos now I'm like wow you
made
it good job people like I'm going to get
my first tattoo like what's why let me
show you what's going to happen I just I
feel like if I see a guy without tattoos
my brain is just like do you not care
believe in anything like do you like you
think they believe in themselves I think
is what's going on with somebody without
tattoos like oh I actually like who I am
well enough to not ruin
it tattoos are like fucking an old dog
you don't like that won't die like this
is just around now I got to get used to
this thing I love what what which ones
don't you like they're all stupid I like
the palm trees that was yeah there an
alien landing on a beach I love that UFO
this is a it's a grim reaper it says
party
pooper and it's that's a cover up cuz I
thought the other tattoo was
dumb what was the other it was a clock
with
wings which I got when I was 20 time F
get it it was like may as well just get
popsicle stick jokes tattooed all over
this one says whoops that's funny
that's good good conversation I got that
that's that old one too man and then are
they all over you or just your arms arms
and then I got my one leg with a bunch
of silly what I got like Jesus with Bob
Seager lyrics oh that's cool rambling
Gambling Man I did a I put a pentagram
underneath that CU I had to balance some
God and Devil
shit I got I got the pig from uh from
the pork chop Express from big trouble
and Little China shut says kind of
invincible underneath
it or over it I don't remember I don't
look at them I don't check in on them
and like how did you like how old were
you when you got like what was the
process of going through that I there's
all these tattoos that I want and I'm
kind of like I get like 70% there and
I'm curious the other 30% you see this
is why I got I got in trouble for saying
this a while ago I think I was on hot
ones and it was before Anthony Bourdain
took took an exit but I was I was
talking about his tattoos I'm like he
got them all within like one year like a
new Suicide Girl and
then that joke didn't age well or
whatever but yeah when you see somebody
gets one and then within like 18 months
they just got it done like there's
nothing interesting about like a themed
sleeve like all that says like good you
could sit still for a while like I want
to see individual like oh this what I
got with my buddy and we were doing and
then this one that was a crazy night
like that's the story I'd rather see
with the tattoos and something silly and
funny I do like somebody like oh they
didn't take it too seriously but they
like it's the universe sure it is dude
that's the arm you beat off with who
cares yeah yeah I guess I just I feel
kind of like not having I have white
tattoos and then I have like one or two
over here but I feel very um you have
white tattoos yeah they use white ink so
see right there so that like it's kind
of a non-committal all it just sums me
up in a nutshell tattoo but not at Aller
yeah it's just like I I don't want to
commit to it does it stay it's just for
me I see it so it look kind of looks
like a scar it chair Hur 10 times as
much and no one can see it but hurt hurt
worse than hitting your arm on that
chair
Again by the way I did it over here too
and I think I was able to I think it's
when you closed your eyes because we had
a real moment I was like fuck I I don't
know why I'm struggling with this chair
I think I'm nervous around you I don't
know why I'm the no I put my thing arm
here and I missed it and I turned it
into like I'm just going to be this
person that's like sing I'm actually
cool I'm actually just really
cool I'm obsessed with um I never know
if I'm going to get along with someone
who has a cat oh really m not I I would
love to understand cat I would love to
have cats I I'm fascinated by them I
just I think they're like haunted and
I'm too insecure to have them cuz they
make me feel bad about
myself I think that says more about you
than the
cat the cat absolutely I don't think
that's the intention cat you know you
know cats if you die they will eat your
face within 24 hours I uh no I was at a
house where there was a cat that was
rescued from a house that the previous
owner had taken an exit okay and I woke
up with the cat sitting on my chest
while I was sleeping knowing that that
cat maybe had
already gotten a taste for
something that how did you get the cat
it was I was I staying at a friend's
house uh and so the cat was at at the
friend's house like do you remember I
don't remember if it was and I love cats
so I'm like I'm on board with Tales from
the dark side or Tales from the Crypt
did you ever watch that Tales from the
crip The Nine Lives episode the episode
where the cat follows
Pano oh no no this is a different one
tell me the one you're going to talk
about cuz I'm oh I'm psyched to talk
about this one the cat follows him and
follows him and and stalks him and then
it goes into his mouth and kills him by
going into his stomach oh that's a
crazier one than I was thinking of oh
what's yours the one I was thinking was
a tailes from the Crypt and uh so Joe
pants out is like a like a homeless like
a hobo and so this this uh doctor gets a
hold he's like I'm gon to give you this
much money for an experimental surgery
I'm going to take the organ that comes
out of the the thing that gives a cat n
lives I'm going to take it out of the
cat I'm going to put it into you and
he's like a a hobo a drunk guy on the
street he like oh why not and so he does
that and he enters the circus and so in
the circus his thing is that he will die
he knows he has nine times that he can
die and he makes all this money dying in
different way like in the circus way
like the guy shoots him with an arrow or
something and so his final trick is he's
getting buried alive and he's telling
the whole story from being uh in a gra
in a grave underground and the end of
the stories he goes and all I got all
this Fame because he winds up turning on
the scientist or the doctor and he goes
and I got all this just from that one
cat that gave his life and then he
realized that the cat had to die once so
he didn't do the math correctly so he
was actually this was the 10th time he
was going to die and he was going to die
buried in the ground and he realized
that in the ground and now I thought
that was the coolest thing I'd ever like
this is what all entertainment should be
this is a twist ending it was kind of
funny it's scary Joe pantalan a fun
little weird guy like it was everything
I wanted in a in a TV show when I was a
little kid yeah I was like 8 years old
I'm like well this is the top of
entertainment nothing nothing's going to
beat this I don't even know why you got
the Oscars if this is out this is a
thing you're done we're done you guys
can pack up and go home platoon take a
hike who needs it this guy the cat died
the cat died once and they didn't do the
math genius twist endings and night get
out of here I feel like a lot of comics
watched a lot of Horror coming up yeah I
got I definitely got raised by cable
like we got C like like good cable also
do you have siblings yeah have a sister
older younger younger not by much like a
year and a half yeah oh interesting um
so I had a much older brother so I saw
way older stuff and there was nothing my
parents could really do about it so I
feel like I saw horrific stuff like way
too early what was the scariest thing
you saw that you could remember seeing
at a young age okay there was a again
Tales from the dark side or Tales from
the Crypt Pat I just sent you texted you
the of a different one this was a
recurring one where the cat would go
into people's mouths um uh I also love
that former horror movies are now
comedies cuz the special effects are so
bad and because it's just like a weird
puppet or something yeah we kind have a
good time with them it's just they're so
funny now that's what metalheads were
good for cuz metalheads knew that early
on that's so true like what are you
scared it's hilarious look how fake that
is like thank you metalheads for making
me not afraid of
monsters wait so he's wait the cat's now
attacking the woman
yeah come on this is hilarious it's it's
so good it's so good dude it's so good
cuz you know the actor had to sit there
with the fake cat on their face just
like are we good are the light are
lights good but I also love the person
that was like we got it we can go home
like you got it did you guys I can't
breathe in this thing we got I got I got
maybe two three takes in me but I can't
this thing is so was this a real
taxidermized cat we need to I'm I'm
actually allergic so this is there is an
element of fear that didn't bring him to
the table on this but like there there
was another one where the cat goes into
the person's mouth light coming out of
it oh maybe will you see if that's a
thing I think it was Tales from the Dark
Side there was another one called Tales
from the crip if a horror movie makes
you afraid of water fuck you dude so it
was a blob that that was Tales from the
crip part two and no I'm sorry that is
creep show O it was a lake yeah the BL
in the lake that is a I believe the
second Creep Show you know when
teenagers are going to a lake something
bad's going to happen never works out
they go they go out and there's like a
floating wood thing and they're all on
it and they're enjoy that hand job it's
the last you're ever going to get and
then so one gets sucked in and then it
turns into like bones remember and then
one girl finally gets away and she like
lays down on the beach to like I escaped
the thing and then it rises up on top of
her yep that I believe that is the
second Creep Show movie the first Creep
Show movie I would bet I can't find it
there's a licensing thing like I got to
go get the actual VHS from somewhere I
would bet that that would still scare
the living shit out of me the first one
CU that was all the vignettes and it was
that's exactly what it was that's the
old guy from Christmas Vacation
okay okay I might have the one look at
him tell tell me this cat comes out of
about yeah look at him look at him go
look at this little guy look at this
little guy still adorable still adorable
to me look at how cute this guy look at
that good job that's who gets an award
you give listen we already got the Puppy
Bowl where are the animal trying to go
his mouth they trying to go watch get in
there watch watch come on come on no now
get him get him come on what's he trying
to do oh he's just he's just giving him
the hex he's okay now he's just he
couldn't take his medicines oh oh he got
him wait something the cat has something
else up his sleeve I tell you that right
now oh wow okay get that cat an a ward
give that cat anemy I hate you I didn't
realize every I don't remember everyone
being in a wheelchair in this in this
show but going back I guess this was a
recurring theme cat's got your tongue
1990 that's what it's called yeah oh
that's the whole movie all right well
now I got something to do tonight oh
this is the one oh this is it this is it
traumatic I can't we had cats in the
house and I was just like I still think
this is it it follows him around look at
him go it follows him around the whole
movie oh get in there oh he's like I
mean he like trying to eat a seven later
burrito there he goes there he
goes look at the tail
wagon and the cat oh still
blinking I what
like why was oh the tail I again there
he goes there he
goes then I come up at the end the
scariest part last to the logo get to
the
logo I watched that on a loop as a I
don't know six seveny old yeah yeah is
that why cat I'm scared of cats I mean
help me I guess well I'm trying to think
of like if anything traumatized me to
the point where it affected me later in
life I just I I just want to be a cat
person and I American Werewolf in
London i' low-lying
Fog never see a field where like the fog
just comes up to your chest yeah in
Portland where you live
yeah yeah I didn't think about that yeah
fog is dicey cuz like what's under there
I legit we would get stoned in in
suburban Chicago land and we were like
we're driving in the Mississippi just we
were real bored kids and the Mississippi
is like three and a half hours so we'd
make it about half hour to the Fox River
and we're like good enough but I
remember we pulled off in some Farmland
to turn around and I had to pee and I
went out into the farmland and I was
like I'm just high and giggly but then I
started thinking about American Werewolf
in London and pants around my ankles ran
back to the car with piss all over
myself and I just got in the car like
what happened I'm like I can't even
start with you guys let's just go home
it's late like yeah so didn't PE peed on
myself I was already but that I remember
that movie affected me and that is a
comedy that is build as a comedy yeah
totally but the scary parts in that were
scary I think I also uh Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory did a number on me um
I must say because there was a lot of
like the kid that got stuck in the tube
oh that's just a good claustrophobia
freak totally like SL water slides for a
m like I always thought about that scene
where he was like you know cuz none of
those kids have survived what happened
to them in that movie but because movie
Magic but um yeah that always stressed
me out when I would see like water
slides and stuff I couldn't that was in
the same era like I grew up like the
baby Jessica was a big thing H remember
that when the baby fell in in the well
documentary about no like just it was a
it was a real life event where this baby
fell in a well God and uh yeah that's
not it that's I hated that I hated that
scene
God Jean Wilder just like wow these kids
are dying crazy well apparently when we
were watching it as a kid we were like
like but the commentary I watched it
recently again well over the pandemic it
was like that we had three years to just
waste our lives and I started rewatching
all the stuff we watched when we were
kids just to like see what happened just
to R terrorize yourself just to do
forensics on like what went wrong um and
uh that I read about it it's like a
commentary on parents not disciplining
their kids well I mean I got that from
when I was a kid I didn't really my
parents were like see what happens when
you didn't listen to your parents see
these are all spoiled brats looks look
what's happened to him well see I
watched it alone at a stranger's house
so no one explained it to me well that's
how I watched The Shining for the first
time when I was about 10 years old and I
was I was starting it I was sitting in
my kitchen and it was at night and I'm
starting it my mom goes The Shining ho
that's a scary one and then she went to
bed she just she just let me but she
loves scary movies I think she know like
it's why like all the True Crime stuff
now I'm like I don't know what why it's
blown up and people like it's soothes
people that are anxious cuz maybe it's
saying like yeah you're not just anxious
for no reason there is terrible stuff in
the world that you can kind of observe
from a distance with these podcasts or
everything like I I mean I am a little
at odds with how much money is made off
of a witty retelling of an actual
heinous crime totally but it is also
that that's the justification for is
it's like leveling off like people
anxiety of like well things are crazy
out there and I'm not being paranoid the
world's nuts as long as it doesn't you
know make you a shut in I guess two
things I wonder about that one thing I
heard about how like at least women love
um True Crime so much cuz it's like
researching what could happen to you
it's like uh uh rubbernecking we do it
to like go like what went wrong so we
don't do that like we're sort of
magnetically looking at it and then also
the other thing about true CRI is it
like the like modern day Roman Coliseum
I mean humans 3 400 years ago used to go
to an auditorium and just watch people
get torn apart Yeah by like elephants
yeah I think it was more Tigers the
elephants were were bigger I was going
to say Tigers but that's what everyone
says and they did use elephants they
would have fights where like a tiger
would fight an elephant for like 12
hours you know what made me laugh the
most I went to the col in Rome and they
would talk about how they wouldn't know
what animal it was going to be like cuz
it would pop up from the ground yeah and
what if you're just like baby
goats now you have to kill them like
there's no win for them cuz like then
they have to slay like nothing but
puppies because it's them like only one
entity can leave alive but then
everybody hates him cuz the guy had to
kill a bunch of puppies he's like you
know what fuck it let them eat let them
eat me I don't want this on my shoulders
I don't want this blood on my hands let
them slowly nibble me to
death something I don't I'm not going to
be that guy I'm not going to be like
they tell you like they're like they
would you know like I just you know I
rescue horses so you know I grow up
around horses so it's like they're like
oh they used to tie a horse to each arm
leg leg leg and then it would tear a
person apart drawn and quartered horses
don't do that they don't run that way
they all run together like it was Sam
Harris did an episode about this it was
so much worse like they were like okay
we're going to tie a horse to the ankles
and the wrist and all just going to run
they're going to do what we want them to
do doesn't happen they all stood there
weird there's just a writer's room of
figuring out how to torture somebody
like all right yeah see that wasn't the
horses wouldn't that never worked that
way there's no way it worked like that I
mean if they just kept whip whipping the
horses I guess they could have done that
but all horses usually a herd will
follow one horse the guy in the middle
is like I mean I'm uncomfortable don't
get me wrong but it's really not I mean
I don't know if like goal is to get me
pulled apart I'm just he probably got
trampled by two that were going One
Direction and just like did yoga to
death all right guys back to the drawing
board uh all right four horses weren't
it I think maybe
two maybe we tried to maybe if he's
allergic to horses we might we might
have a funny death on our hand I mean he
was sneezing a lot before you know the
one leg went off and then that took his
attention there's apparently someone
that was always standing by just to kill
the person if it was taking too long
how Humane of them which is like how do
you get that job and who decides it's
time to call it it's like giving someone
the light when they're dying you're just
like this is bombing like just I got a
thing at 2:30 so I here's something we
could just kill him from the get-go we
we got the guy doing the hood with the
ax he's doing a great job people love it
they come out to they come and watch it
I went to a when I was little we went to
Europe on vacation I remember it was in
Germany and it was before every city can
I just ask how that happens my dad
worked works for the airlines or worked
for the Airlines and so yeah we were
like not rich but had flight benefits so
I got to like go to cool places and I
was thankful for that so we're in
Germany and we went to the Torture
Museum cuz this you know how old are you
I I think I was like third grade or
fourth grade it's funny because you my
parents are good people I don't want
this to reflect on them no I just I'm
trying to figure out how you got so
funny with loving parents and I think we
figured it out yeah yeah you know it's
like it's interesting but then that's
you're talking about things you remember
cuz now every city kind of has one and I
think I heard that a lot of these might
be
fictionalized I don't know I feel like
the Germans went pretty hard well I
remember seeing the Iron Maiden is that
what is that is that the thing with all
the spikes yeah that's that but the one
I remember the most is how they said
they would like take a weel like a wagon
wheel and like pulverize somebody with
it and then weave them in between the
spokes Jesus this is what this is what I
took I'm still shitty at uh
multiplication time taes don't remember
those but they would weave the the the
pulverized but yeah there you go that's
the one there it is yeah like that wait
so how does this pulverize exper oh
maybe this is something else they just
twirled them or something I don't know
they just nause them to death yeah I
mean I I'm I'm not a big fan of the
merry go rounds this is oh this person
is that someone that had to suck a shit
out of a pig maybe he maybe he's blowing
into it oh
bummer well now the is the pig eaten or
is the pig that's like the first human
centipede I knew it that little human
Kebab does this this guy's holding a
ring up he's proposing he like you're
the kind of freak I've been looking for
man now listen the traditionalists are
going to frown on this
but I think you're I think you're the
fellow for me I guess does this bum you
out that humans are capable of this like
this wasn't that long ago I mean does
that bum me out or the fact that there's
a museum now to be like hey check it out
like we could forget about it that's
actually wait I want that horse statue
um yeah that's I think they did I don't
think that's a horse statue what's weird
I think something else was going on with
that what's worse that humans actually
tortured other humans or that other
humans were like let's make a museum out
of this or that people actually showed
up with their children I don't know are
they all can they all just be bad can
all just be a bad thing I mean is it
worse that there's probably still people
getting tortured now but like well turn
society's taking a different angle on it
so it's true no more public hangings I
guess but we do like public shaming on
Twitter like when people get canceled
isn't that just like a public
shaming that mean the C like is any
nobody's canceled no one's 100% nobody
can I'm totally with you Mak but but to
join in and mock try it's kind of like
we're doing we're it's like a mob do you
I'm getting to a point now where like I
you know I'm like OB begrudgingly
participating in social media because of
comedy and everything and like more and
more I think there's like a general Mala
towards it like like I think maybe like
there's an amount of people like why am
I looking at this why am I getting mad
like there's like a general feeling of
like yeah I got the account I look at it
once in a while and I think that's such
a good thing yeah I think it's a really
really good thing like yeah I don't like
you see somebody hasn't posted in like
three months like good for you that's
awesome like like jezel Nick I'm like
weirdly Star Struck by him because I've
known him for we started around the same
almost 20 years but he didn't post on
social media for like four years and
then I got like nervous around him
because I was like Star Struck by his
restraint or I just thought he was
better than me I don't know anything
about you how am I supposed to hang out
I was like so uncomfortable and like
weird like like I had a crush on him or
something just because do you're so
mysterious yeah and he's also like a bad
boy you know and also like you don't
give a fuck like you're a comic but you
don't he's like I'm funny enough to not
need to do that he just like made me
have to look in the mirror jealous I
know it's so cool like so you're just
like secure with yourself without likes
yeah you're the you're the bad boy
you're exactly that guy and a high
school like leather jacket totally
you're not even going to the dance
what
what I don't know maybe I'll show up
cigarette
like this
guy that's totally what it was I was I
want to be like that so much except I'm
this guy I hope you come to my
should swipe up for fucking a carrot
stick in my beard do you like me I guess
I don't care I don't like me either um
so you're you're from from Chicago I
love that you shot your special in
Minneapolis right yeah at AC yeah and
then okay I'm obsessed with this the
older you get the more you become where
you're from the more you're from where
you're from yeah I don't know what that
even it just there's so I started
putting butter out like in the South you
put the butter out it's just out like
room temperature you don't put in the
fridge is it the butter Dome what do
they call it butter it's a dish butter
dish it's in a dish oh you're not doing
the Bell it's like it's a square it's an
Etsy vintage it's got but you know the
Bell right I with the handle yeah but it
goes in water so there's not air getting
to the butter but it's still out at room
temperature okay this I'm listening what
are you talking about now this is not
what I thought would happen
today the butter BT well that we go from
gluey jizz to like you you using a
butter
bill which sounds like a cure for gluey
jizz but it's you have see it goes in
the water so the bacteria is not get
into the butter cuz it's sealed by the
water is this a Midwest thing I just
found out about it a couple years ago
where somebody had it and I was like
weirded out by it I've never heard of
this yeah this is wild so the water oh
so there's a little bit of water in
there and so there's not air coming into
contact with your butter but it's still
room temperature but water can be carry
germs I mean listen if you want to pick
it apart pick it apart but I'm just
saying I don't know if this is can we is
this yeah you don't put your hand in the
water is this a is this a don't fill it
up with a
toilet a small dish of water is this but
what is the point is it really old or
really new I can't tell is this an
oldtime Renaissance thing did you get
this at the gift shop of the Torture
Museum I don't know I've never heard of
this people watching public torture
loved a nice uh C users who bought these
tickets also bought there's you know
there's the plague in the air so you
keep the butter in the water so keeps
the butter at Perfect spreading
consistency the anatomy of a butter Bell
spread consistency huh huh yeah no I do
I put it out and I just recently started
doing it I recently started after you
cook bacon or grease you put it in a cup
and it just stays on your sink for
coffee can oh yeah just grease is just
always kind of there cuz it can't go
down the sink nope selling a little or a
lot Shopify helps you do your thing
however you cha-ching Shopify is the
global Commerce platform that helps you
sell at every stage of your business
from the laun your online shop stage to
the first sorry this is my baby which I
might um look we'll see which option
shopbop has for is there an adoption
section uh and then it'll take you all
the way to the real life store stage all
the way to the did we just hit a million
orders stage Shopify is there to help
you grow whether you're selling scented
soap or trinkets or Doats in bits or
spooky ch Keys Shopify helps you sell
everywhere from their all-in-one
Commerce platform to their in-person POS
system wherever and whatever you're
selling shopify's got you covered
Shopify helps you turn browsers into
buyers with the internet's best
converting checkout 36% better on
average compared to other leading
Commerce platforms and sell more with
less less effort thanks to Shopify magic
your AI powered Allstar for me it's all
about a real connection with your
customers like if you can reach out to
them know where they're from see a list
of where in the USA they are you can
start getting a real understanding of
why people buy and why your next round
of product will be even more dialed in
like I like to like on Shopify you can
see where everyone who who bought in my
case my book so I was able to then
customize my tour schedule and go see
those people and go do standup so I
could sign their books in person slam
dunk I'm not a businessman I'm a
business man Shopify Powers 10% of all
e-commerce in the US and Shopify is the
global force behind all birds rothis
Brooklyn and millions of other
entrepreneurs of every size across 175
country plus Shopify countries that was
plural and you know it plus shopify's
award-winning help is there to support
your success every step of the way
because businesses that grow they grow
as Shopify sign up for a $1 per month
trial period at shopify.com Whitney all
lowercase please don't be an uppercase
weirdo go to shopify.com Whitney now to
grow your business no matter what stage
you're in shopify.com
slwt this episode is brought to you by
better help look when a new year rolls
around we get obsessed with how to
change ourselves instead of just
expanding on what we're already doing
right there are some things that I would
like to change like I would ideally like
to change being so absent minded that I
send a text about someone to the person
it's about not great don't love it okay
love to maybe stop Googling hit Hitler
in 2024 not my favorite thing about
myself what I do want to double down on
that I'm already doing right is therapy
not speech therapy as you can tell mind
therapy therapy helps you find your
strengths so that you can ditch the
extreme resolutions and make changes
that really stick they stick just about
as much as this Baby's puke has stuck to
my nipple today I go to therapy okay you
know this about me I'm open about this
and when I stopped going to therapy for
six months guess what happened I
suddenly had blue hair Google it therapy
helps me get my internal needs met
internally instead of going outside
myself to alcohol drugs online shopping
Instagram you name it I've used it to
avoid looking at myself therapy helps me
stay present instead of disassociating
through life because that's yucky folks
if you're thinking of starting therapy
give better help a try it's entirely
online designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
that's what they say it in in England
sesual just fill out a brief
questionnaire and get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
any time any literally any time for
literally no additional charge okay
celebrate the progress you've already
made visit betterhelp.com Whitney today
get 10% off your first month that's
better help
hp.com
Whitney what are like some Midwestern
things that you only see in the midwest
because that's the one part of the
country I
don't I'm trying like I feel like I get
more of an accent I don't think I have
that much of an accent but I think it
comes out a little bit more M I also go
back a lot yeah I'm back there pretty
often is the best place to tour I mean
it's I mean it rules I'm trying to think
of like anything that's like I think
it's more of just a mat talk about in
the special just the general attitude of
life and self-help of like yeah things
aren't going to be good like you don't
like it's life life's not good but you
know it's not good so you're like all
right like good enough like you just set
the bar good enough and if anything
blips Over the Bar you're like I'm
grateful for this but it also cannot
stay because if it stays like I have
this uh idea that luck is a finite
amount like a karmic kind of like if
something good happens something bad has
to happen sure uh but then if something
bad happens like well I probably
deserved it so I this is true I feel
this to be true something good happens
and then it's just like waiting the for
the other shoe to drop like what and so
there's this weird like this this kind
of internal struggle of like you know
everybody's always Comics are always
going to be jealous and they're always
going to be like that so and so got that
thing so and so's getting this sure but
then I have to temper that with like but
look what you have and so I in that way
I think it's good it keeps me humble and
the whole thing of like even if it's
like false humility of like oh thanks I
can't but you know what you get I get
enough complim because I'm not big
enough to be torn down yet I'm like
leave it alone leave it here consistent
give me a B+ that's all I want we're not
getting we're not getting into a good
college we'll go to a state school but
with babbe maybe they'll give us a
couple bucks that's all we need it's all
we need it's always like stay an
underdog as soon as you win too hard
it's like the clock start people want to
take you down like oh no I'm in that
sweet spot so that's like keeps me like
what a weird sick attitude of like I
don't want to get too successful cuz
then that that's a reason for people to
not like me like what kind of fucked up
thinking is that I would like to just
stay out of cat Williams's perview I
would like to just stay out of his wrath
if Cat Williams is talking about me I
have made it I just know that whatever
he were to say about me would be correct
and I would not be able to handle it I
don't have you interacted with Cat
Williams I wrote on the roast of flavor
flave which he hosted so I wrote a lot
of the jokes uh for that roast that he
that were about him okay but I didn't
mean it and you're the funniest and I'm
on your side and I'm sorry I love I love
that guy dude that was everyone's like
it's interesting because I do think if
you are at a point where you're fearless
and talking shit about successful people
and talking shit about Hollywood
everyone just assumes you're on drugs
may I don't know I have no idea he
didn't seem on drugs to me but then
again everyone on drug I didn't watch
that interview either I just again I
just hear about things from people oh
it's can we play some of it I mean so I
got to watch tales from the side and the
Cat Williams interview I I think I
watched like I think I watched a couple
Snippets of it dude it is spectacular it
is the guy showed up to entertain like
there's a lot of I mean sometimes
podcasts included you're like I guess
it's like a casual hang I have a hard
time with this sometimes I'm like joke
and joke we have to do something two up
a clip like I just sort of have a hard
time believing people want to hear us
just like shoot the shit that's a big
like how disposable everything is yeah
but people
Listen to I know and I forget that part
and I'm like oh people do like just
because we hate ourselves doesn't mean
everyone else does like everyone else
likes us a little more than we like
ourselves that's okay you want to talk
about influences Cat Williams influences
me not in a manner of like joke writing
let's just say my material is not going
to overlap with his so much but as far
as like showing up to entertain like
where you watch how many Comics
especially like so I think my Heyday or
like when I kind of popped was the a
really and it was the height of like the
alternative like stand up and the jokes
are the star of the show so there's no
performance I'm just going to tell you
these observations and seeing Cat
Williams use a whole stage and roll out
in like a $50,000 belt
buckle in a $2,000 hair qua and within
five minutes just be a sweating mess
who's like sliding into first base back
and forth that's a show I need to be
there's no reason you can't
also like be a comedian but like put on
a show people came out people came out
act like you're excited to be there hey
maybe don't lean on the brick wall come
off the brick wall yeah I'm going to
move around a little bit cuz I was like
I move a little bit and i' watch a video
of myself I'm like that's a cardboard
cut out of you you could tell the jokes
from behind the curtain if you wanted to
and so that like watching that like oh
he's going to give them their money's
worth yeah that's it and that was like a
big influence like to watch that like I
can like break a sweat I can enjoy
myself more on stage and get into it
yeah 100% and be S and be silly like
goof around you were so goofy in this
last one in the best way I was having
fun on that it very made me laugh out
loud when you picked a piece of lint off
your I like right at the beginning tell
fuck all right but it was so like it was
I love moments where you see the 10,000
hours when you see how long someone's
been doing something because it was like
so fluid and smooth like he was doing
this like like well-crafted joke and was
like I have to get this off my pants cuz
I can't look like shit for this special
it was just like so and then went right
back into it I I'm so glad you left that
in because it shows like how long you've
been doing this and how hard you work
it's like it it's like being able to
hang out like no matter what happens in
the room being able to play off it I
know we're in the Heyday of like crowd
work comedy which people do it well
there are people that do it well but I
the same thing that's been that's a
great way to put out a clip of yourself
that's not burning material I do
material that's what I got that's it's a
different way to do things and I see
that that's successful but I'm not going
to forcefully do crowd work just to get
a clip I I I feel that bubble will burst
soon as well now people show up yelling
I mean we've now encouraged the audience
to to yell at us I would really I will
look into the camera please that is not
what we want you to do you're not
helping you're not
helping people dress to be on camera now
everyone's wearing like cowgirl hats
with like like everyone's like oh I'm
going to be on camera yeah what this
isn't the Price Is Right just sit there
and laugh at the joke if I want to talk
to you then I'll talk to you but it's
not it's not like well come on down
you're gonna play Plinko I don't give a
shit I'm glad you're there I don't even
make eye content I look at the lights on
purpose so if you see me looking in the
audience it's cuz I've been staring at
the lights long enough that I can't see
anybody and it looks like I'm engaging
but I've actually seared my corneas like
if I actually
like dealt with the fact that there were
human beings watching me I wouldn't be
able to say any of this any no matter
who I look at no matter how well the
show's going the one person I'm like I
doing pretty good let's go it's one dude
just always like I'm the worst nobody's
ever been worse at comedy than me I'm
I'll quit now I'll quit now I'll leave
now um would you say that you have non
work related Hobbies I'm in the market
for one that's all I have outside play
guitar yeah but not good but what is the
I play music I play music I do
everything I do I do poorly and it's the
most refreshing thing in the world
because I care about standup so much and
I care about the quality of that which
means I can be bad at all these other
things and just do them for fun CU I'm
not a competitive person like I didn't
grow up like well I'm going to do
something I'm going to do it well I grew
up like I'm going try this thing for a
little while and spend too much money on
a hobby that you just made me realize
something I am so competitive and hard
on myself that's why I can't do a hobby
cuz I can't be bad at it it's I it makes
me mad hate myself well I'm the person
at game night that's like time and every
was like uh you okay bitch I mean there
there's a level of success uh
discrepancy here as to that shows that
does show shut up shut up I hate you I
don't even have the one TV with my face
on it for my podcast I I zoom from the
basement for mine but a little bit of a
case for parents that didn't love you
but know oh mine love me a whole bunch
godamn them but you do play guitar like
what else do you no I I have like a
whole room of just instruments that I
suck at all of them and it's it rules
like the H so I got the house which is
such a relatable premise in
2024 uh it's fun to do jokes about your
house in Portland to people that are
taking a break from throwing trash cans
through Starbucks Windows to come see
the show
uh it's like I didn't say I started my
own space program it's a fucking I'm in
my mid mid to late
40s I think it's okay that I did
this everybody's like class Trader El
Hollywood asshole I did I got booed do I
like boo I'm like what I thought we
hated landlords so I'm not doing a
landlord thing I hate me for this what
do you want renting is throwing money I
can't win so I have one room it's that
is just I got drums and guitars and I
just go from each one like it's it's
it's the apartment that Tom Hanks has
from Big from Big
yeah I got too many mountain bikes I'm
bad at I'm bad on one of them but now
each of them are for different scenarios
where I'm like I'm gonna be bad on this
kind of Trail I'm
be I did I got yeah so I I do I do bike
ride when I can uh I like I like to just
make stupid sounds with instruments not
good that nobody's ever going to hear
them right but that's that's like the
best night for me is to just have a
couple beers and try and learn some ACDC
songs tabs I can't read music but just
sit down there your gal where's your gal
and all this she's watching she's
somewhere with earplugs
in she no she so yeah we're splitting
time so uh we'll be now she'll be in La
primarily I'll be in Oregon some of the
time because she's back here in the mix
but she
also she'll put her headphones on and do
whatever she'll go off go roller skating
or something we about like pandemic was
awesome she roller skates yeah do I have
to like do I have to like are people fun
like when I hear I'm all we that's all
we did was have fun during the pandemic
I know I'm not that doesn't sound great
but that sounds great I lost my mind
yeah there was nights like I'm playing
bad guitar she's like roller skating in
the living room with a beer in her hand
I'm like what we're just doing it this
is kind of what we're we're not supposed
to be doing anything else you been
shelter in place no no problem been
training for this my whole life
yeah 10 years you've been together yeah
yeah I'm not trying to be this person
just okay all right just curious why not
get married cuz I think at 10 years
you're already domestic Partners yeah
because if you get married the first
time then you got to get married a
second time and starts off this whole
mess do you think part of your success
in the relationship is the fact that you
didn't get married and put like pressure
on it or spend money on I think so I
think we're both like we'll threaten
each other we fucking get married okay
all right calm down calm
down yeah I think both of us saw it as
like I don't know what
the I just don't I I I I mean this is a
this is a terrible metaphor that I've
used before it's like you're in a room
with a door on it and you can't leave
the room all right but I like the room
love the room it's my favorite room all
right now we're going to put a lock on
the door now I'm all I'm going to do is
think about shit what's on the other
side of that door other there's a lock
on it I can't get out like that's me
telling you know what's on the other
side what's that
butts yeah but there's a there's a butt
in the room
too that's one butt yeah it's a
butt okay so that's the key great ass
yeah no I just I I
don't it's not like I'm not trying to be
like all punk rock like man what kind of
institution do you know
just I I just didn't it didn't well
we're both kind of like look at us we're
still doing the thing it's actually it's
so cool I just feel like for some reason
reason it looks really cool on you I'm
just trying to think about this cuz I
just feel like as a woman Once you turn
like 40 saying boyfriend is a little
rough yeah I uh I've been I take to
saying the misses the misses is good
which I think is fun yeah little little
tip of the Hat m is at home I say my
dude but that's kind of like I don't
know I don't think is that like calling
a guy a chick like the version of chick
I don't know which I don't mind I think
it's hot I mean dudes aren't bad I I'm
not like that's my chick I'm not the guy
who can say that's my chick lady lady
friend Partners
fuck what do you call women I think it's
all like I was with somebody GS a lot
gal
lasses your hat it feels this has big
Irish Lassie not from the
1800s what do you do think I just got
here on a boat I remember I was um where
do you keep your
madams I was seeing someone who uh would
come home from work and he was like well
um there was this young lady in the
office today and we were talking about
and I was like mhm
just say young is weird to like put an
adjective in front of it that's bumping
me a little bit how old was this guy
that was saying it I mean if he's 24 is
a weird thing yeah 37 cuz then I'm like
I'm just thinking about like how young
was she and he's like oh like 25 and I'm
like well you could just say woman at
that right or girl I don't know I I
don't have an answer young lady sounds
more polite than
lady but young so there's this lady you
that's never the start of a good story
so there's this lady and she's real nice
no but like oh just young lady this
usually means it's going to be a
complimentary tale ladies like tell you
to turn your music down and call the
cops on you for sure yeah young lady
though it's weird to do math on
someone's age and bring it into the
descript well it's it's it's just
younger than him but why does that
matter in the story cuz maybe it's uh
he's talking about how see this is he
was surprised she did stuff for herself
or something this is why I'm single cuz
I get stuck on formalities that I can't
drop it this this young lady at the
office she opened the door for herself
that was that was
flabbergasted I didn't know what to do
in the face of that Liberation stuff's
going pretty Qui um I'm obsessed with
your special it's called dirtnap yeah
out dirtnap named after rip cat oh yeah
I'm I'm a cat guy are you get a new one
no if it's it's cats are just out there
just like that whole story the cat just
started Living with us so I I one time
tried to rescue a cat yeah twice I tried
to rescue cats that were outside
climbing your mouth eat your soul one of
them I got in the middle of the night I
drove in La there's coyotes everywhere I
see a coyote and then I keep driving
half a mile I see a cat I'm like oh my
God this is wild I got to stop I got to
get this cat super like furry like the
long hair cats you know I go out pick it
up put it in the car a bob cat did you
get a bob cat I uh put it in my car take
it to the vet I'm like we need to find
its owner and T and let's rescue this
cat whatever give it call the owner uh I
guess the cat had been taken to
different vets every night that week
because people saw the cat outside
apparently when they're ready to die
they just
leave to go die yeah yeah and so the
owner was like she's trying to die can
you please stop picking her up and I was
like no I can't no I'm not Janice
somebody found a goddamn cat again she's
like it have to kill it ourselves she
said he said she says it cost me $400
every time cuz then I have to go to the
vet it's been there overnight like we
need to stop picking it up and then the
next night I saw it I was like I'm not
leaving this year and then we went back
to the vat and I was like I'll split
this with you but I'm not going to just
like no drive by your cat no I can't now
that I know that That's The
Story You're Psy go and but she's like
give it the Dignity of its own
experience to go out and die and I was
like I don't get
cats I don't get how this relationship
works it's it's also very heavy metal
and then time to die I'm off to the
woods like what and then there was a cat
on another Street of mine see it outside
bring in the cat whole thing I'm like
this three days later I'm like okay I'm
posting this on Instagram someone come
rescue this cat I've been fostering it
put it on Instagram put it up 2 hours
later knock on my door the neighbor's
like did you just try to get my cat
adopted out I'm
like wait so your cats just outside all
the time like and for three days you
didn't like ask anyone where it was yeah
that's that's what cats do are they
supposed to be domesticated I feel like
abusing them by bringing them into house
that's that was the whole situation it's
it's totally like here's a pet door you
make your own hours you know it's a real
work from home situation like all right
you know every podcast cast we like
we're sponsored by simply safe we just
set it up to point at the pet door we
didn't KN we didn't set up any of the
home alarms but we knew when the cat was
coming and going like a trail cam wake
up in the middle of night oh she's in
the house we got real excited I mean
cats used to be worshiped like in like
they would WR put cats in like mummies
like tombs and stuff yeah yeah in
ancient Egypt and everything they would
mummify them I mean my theory is that
like you know dudes get all hardons
about dogs and whatever and I but I
think it's it's such a control thing
like oh you show off your dog because of
how much it listens to you like oh great
you feed scare an animal yeah you scare
an animal and make it afraid enough to
listen to you otherwise it won't eat
that's not cool to me at all you know
that does like shit do this like oh what
a fun obedient thing that doesn't think
for itself like that's not love that's
not this is why you're not getting
married yeah I I don't want I don't want
that kind of same thing the cat's like
what's go hey I mean everybody's done
the the dogs versus cats joke but that's
what's awesome about it where's the cat
I don't know it took off the other day
it's out there whing around come back
when it knows what's good for it and
that yeah so that's what I I've always
had cats growing up and they were always
just outdoor cats that had come back
after like getting in a fight and you're
like should we give it a beer think we
should give it a be looks like it earned
a beer it looks like it wants a beer
that's what you want after a fight and
so yeah that most that special is a 45
minute story about moving to the suburbs
it's incredible it's incredible it
really made me want to have a
relationship with a cat and that is hard
to do um okay I want to say your tour
dat's real quick cuz you're going to be
in Rochester New York at the Carlson
comedy at Carlson January 25th and 27th
February 23rd and 24th you're going to
be at Funny Bone in Omaha I love that
club March 1st through 3D I'm so
dyslexic that it's amazing I just did
that March 1st through third Helium
Comedy Club in Philly let's go March
14th through 16th Comedy Club of Kansas
City I haven't done that one I think
it's a newer one newer one it sounds
like cuz I think it was Kansas City what
was the other one I think it's an improv
there yes that's true March 22 to 24
laugh shop comedy club in Calgary Canada
yeah I kind of have a relationship with
Calgary wow I had a whole story on well
I had a whole story on another special
where I I was trying to go to Calgary to
do shows and I got turned around cuz I
had a DUI on my record so they they
kicked me out of Calgary SI shit all
over Calgary
and now I'm going back there to make a
men it's been years come on we're water
under the bridge I have that with uh
Oxnard oh really they kicked you out of
Oxnard it's a long story it's I tell it
almost every it's right over there I
don't know how they kicked you out we
keep cutting it out every week we tell
it every episode and then cut it out why
are we cutting it out let's let it rip
come on it involves like gangs it's like
it's oh really just don't say the name
of the gangs I don't I have to like go
apologize I have to like go on the
morning news and like talk to the mayor
it's like wait really yeah I don't want
to
like I I don't like the old west I I
don't want to like put you at risk like
it's apparently it's a problem I would
like to hear this whether it's on the
show or not I would before I leave I'd
like to know the story yeah I tell it
every episode I'm like you have to cut
that so let's just not do this rigar
roll thank you for taking the time to do
this dude yeah thanks this is a good
time dude you I like doing things get
out of town you are so funny to me like
is fun I like doing it I still like I
still really really like being a
comedian I don't understand the guys
that are like grumpy like good like then
quit don't talk about Marin like that I
saw him at the store the other night and
he was having a fun time it's so
exciting to see him like smirk and enjoy
himself on stage like see even these old
dogs you can turn them yeah it's I mean
it truly is the best it is the best I
love being on stage now not knowing if
someone's going to attack me yeah I
guess I it's like fun and dangerous
again staying an underdog yeah totally
no ominous obvious threats to my
well-being right now yeah not big enough
to stalk I also think it's weird though
sometimes stalkers latch on it that
doesn't always isn't always the case and
I can't say the person I'm about to say
because then it's going to be revealed
that I don't think they're famous oh I
mean I might I might have had stalkers
and I think they might just be my
friends
now you're like I like your comedy
really what are you doing later you want
go hang out like I just welcome him in
you know we're going to get along just
fine it's hard to get punched when
you're hugging
them Kyle Kain you're the funniest dude
you're like the funniest to me get out
with that I'm obsessed with you hold
there goes the eye contact we were we
were I know we were look at the floor
watching your special was watching with
someone we were crying at the um eating
your cuticles the Panic snacks oh man
and Blues Traveler like there's always
just a reference that is just really T
you tickle me all right really tickle me
I'll take I'm going to keep saying that
till you look I'll make eye contact on
that one sure you tickle me you been
tickled you look down you've been
tickled you just got tickled you been
tickled I love you it's The Great Kyle
canine everybody thank you so much don't
ride elephants I end these
weird
I still don't know
[Music]
how